so I'd like to welcome you to tonight's
class on chess openings we're going
through the Benoni this week and next
week we're covering the old-fashioned
Czech Benoni tonight
so it's it the benoni is a defense
against d4 and blacks first move is c5
and white this you'll see in the end the
notes there that this concedes white a
space advantage right off the bat he
moves his pawn up so his pawns on the
fifth row and it opens up more squares
for white because his pawns are further
advanced than black
now black gets a few things in return
for that concession he gets a tight
center pawn white doesn't command the
whole center with pawn side-by-side cuz
he'll have a pawn chain so it keeps the
position blocked
there's no mating attacks or anything
that black has to worry about it's very
solid in the opening and it's a
maneuvering game so you'll see there's
no brilliant kingside attacks right away
so black plays d6 here white plays c4
white needs to get both his pawns to
support the d5 pawn in this opening so
now now we're at the point where they
have the old way of playing which we're
going to go through tonight b5 it's
called the Czech Benoni and this is by
this was played in Russia Russia Cup
2010 November 12th between Carolyn and
zug in Sep please excuse my very bad
Russian pronunciation so I wanted to
start with this because the
old-fashioned lines not played much and
it's real
only one line it's easy to learn the
modern benoni which is favored by more
modern players is e six and the idea is
to take the son or pawn it opens up the
e-file black plays g6 and puts his
bishop on the open black diagonal and
gets draw strong counter play that's
called the modern Benoni I'll cover that
next week got a handout for you over on
that table so make sure you grab one
before you leave
okay so e5 and you can see white just
blocks the so the characteristic of this
opening see how the center's blocked all
the six pawns three for white and black
they block each other that means there's
not going to be any central attacks by
bishops on d3 to the King side that's
blocked by his own pawns and blacks
Bishop on f8 is hemmed in by the black
pawns he just goes to e7 the knight
comes up this is just normal development
where once the pawns are up you develop
piece after piece till you get your army
from the first rank out and then you
start doing something to move up the
board try to take take as many squares
from your opponent as you can ok so the
Knights pinned white develops this
Knight over cuz he wants to give the
Queen freedom of movement and if Bishop
takes Knight he wants to take back with
the knight black route is Knight up to
f6 and white puts his Bishop where it
protects the two white pawns in the
center now the bishop on d3 has an added
purpose in this pawn structure
eventually black will try to move that
f7 pawn to f5 to trade off the e4 pawn
and the bishop on d3 works through the
e4
pawn onto the f5 square and the pawn can
take it and then the bishop could trade
whatever piece takes back or the bishop
would get an open line the other break
they call these pawn breaks it's where
the black can move pawns to attack white
or where white could move his pawns to
attack the black pawns so the other
black pawn break would be if he moved to
his b7 pawn to b5 and took out the c-4
pot he won't he may try to do that you
have to play a six first and then b5 a
you pray have to move his rook over and
he might have to move his Knight to c7
now White's pawn breaks the one he tries
for his f2 pawn is blocked by his night
as his black's f7 potentially he could
move the f2 pawn the f4 and open up
after he castles that would open up the
rook file up with the rook on f1 and the
other one is to move this pawn up here
and take out that pawn he could open it
and then put a rook here he'd have an
open line for his rook so that's what
you'll see both players doing once they
get castled on everything they'll work
to open up lines for their works with
these pawn moves black castles white
castles now if you look at the notation
it's got the White's move in the left
black box and it's got the plus over
equal sign that's the chest notation in
computers and in books for a slight
advantage for white now the decimal note
0.51 it's a positive number that goes
inside and quantifies White's advantage
and it's based on the fact that 1.00 the
value one is assigned to a pawn so when
you see point five one it means white
as the advantage of half a pawn now
we're only I move eight
it's common for white to have an
advantage of 0.3 of a pawn to half upon
in the opening due to the first move
advantage and as if black plays
correctly he should be able to diminish
that 0.5 if black makes these are minor
mistakes if he makes minor mistakes that
point 5 will start to creep up now black
is not in danger of losing until that
gets near one-one pawn in in that
Grandmaster chess if a grandmaster is
one pawn ahead he usually wins the game
but the the computer that does this
annotation doesn't consider it a one
game till it gets up to about one point
three five which would be one and a
third pawns but it suffice it to say
once you get there one pawn up the
Grandmaster has that one one point
advantage is near a win a big advantage
oh I'd be guessing somewhere around 80
when it gets up yeah it was 80 85 really
a grandmaster who's defending would not
want to get in a position where he's
down by one whole pond that doesn't mean
he's down upon it just means this
position is evaluated as equivalent of
being down upon so all this means is
White has a positional advantage because
there's no material advantage all right
now black plays Knight to a6 and
remember I told you you might come here
here and then play for b5 so that's what
his plan is see that the symbol next to
Knight to a6 it's the question mark
exclamation mark that means it's a
dubious move
it's not a real bad move but it's not
his best move and look how the
evaluation jumped to 0.66 so it went up
point 1/5 of a pawn which is 1/6 of a
pawn so now it had it jumped up another
half pawn that would have been a
question mark a bad move
there's merely a dubious move which
means the black didn't find the best
move okay anyway white plays develops
his rook to e1 even though it's blocked
by the pawn the work is better on e1
work supports the four pawn on f1 it
can't move anywhere it's behind a pawn
on f2 so that improves the rook black
continues with his plan of playing for
b5 now white could stop b5 by playing a
4 but if white moved his pawn here it
would leave a hole in his palm position
C there'd be a pawn here and a pawn here
and a pond here that night could move
here and go into this hole and the
knight would be on the fifth row
attacking the bishop and harassing white
so a4 is what you had called double
edged it does prevent b5 but it gives
the knight a good square White's not
going to do that what white does he
plays a three now who could tell me in
the audience what White's next move
would be if we gave white an extra move
that's right
so sometimes the Grandmaster moves are
quite obvious he does a three he wants
to get b4 and before black gets b5 in
and black can't play it right away
because he'd lose a pawn
okay so this is an interesting point
here white still has a slight advantage
the question is what is blacks best move
now black chooses to retreat his knight
why do you think black retreated his
knight there anybody have an idea but
how does the Knight to d7 help that I
think so I think what he's doing is
switching between both are valid ideas
for black it looks like he's opting to
play one or the other now here's what
the computer says he should have done
the computer thinks that he should have
played a5 giving up the b5 break but
preventing White's B for C that would
allow black to defend his Queen side
better because when white plays here
black will take take and that rook will
be here and this white rook will be here
and he would have custody of the a file
that would give him counter chances and
a better defense on the Queen side so
the computer says that's what he should
have done but he didn't do that he wants
to play for the other break now you see
now in chess you need to have a plan but
you shouldn't have two plans so black
shouldn't be trying for both breaks he
should have concentrated admit well
after he played a5 then he could do the
knight back into play for f4 if he wants
to
so maybe the Knight to d7 isn't such a
bad idea but he should have played the
a5 move first
okay anyway white plays h3 the night
blocks the bishop retreat so now it's a
good time to make the bishop take the
knight or retreat to the h5 where he
can't get back to the Queen side and
he's blocked by the white pawns if he
goes to h5 he didn't want to give up the
bishop for a knight that's a concession
most Square masters prefer bishops
overnights even though the valued at
three pawns each it's closed and that's
supposed to favor Knights he could have
played Bishop takes Knight but he chose
to retreat it now white moves his rook
to b1 obviously now he wants to get the
rook on b1 to support b4 and then he can
take on c5 and open the rook file and
threaten the pawn on b7 black makes a
dubious move now
he put remember I told you that Bishop
was a bad Bishop because it was blocked
by the black pawns
so black knows that and he moves it to
g5 that knight is pinned so the knight
can't take it right away the knight on
f3 because it's pinned to the Queen
so black decides to trade off his black
score Bishop for either the night he
would if this knight moved he loved to
trade it for that Bishop even though
this hasn't moved the problem with this
old-fashioned Czech Pannonia is that
Bishop is blocked by his pawns on black
squares that's why he moved to Bishop to
g5 but the computer says it's the
dubious move and look the it crept up to
0.73 now which it went up 0.2 1/5 of a
pawn you get enough of these dubious
moves and you're going to be a pawn down
pretty soon anyway white takes advantage
of it and plays G
4c he's not gonna trade off his bishop
he's gonna trade a knight for the bishop
so he gets the night for the bishop
black's queen comes up and white chases
it away right away with the knight and
the queen retreats now white made a
reasonable and a good move but he missed
the best move white carried out his plan
of b4 now look what happened to the
valuation it went from point seven three
down the point five one I could have
called before dubious but what really
happened was he missed his best move
anybody have an idea what the best move
is for white it's right there in the
note it's what he should have done is
done Bishop to g5 see attacking the
Queen now black has several options -
that aren't good the first option would
be to move the knight to f6 which would
pin the knight to the Queen then that
night wouldn't do any good and he would
never get his fi pawn break-in would he
remember he retreated the night so he
could play f5 the other thing he could
do he could retreat the Queen he go to
e8
on ei the Queen is blocked on the white
diagonals by the pawn in the night and
you don't want your queen on the first
row anyway the only other option is to
block the bishop which is probably the
best option f6 and it drives the bishop
would go where would the bishop goal if
f6 was played where no see the problem
with going to h4 see those pawns from be
5 f6 g7 that Bishop on h4 can never get
through those pawns if he goes to G
three he hits the five pawn the black
pawn if he stays at age four he's hit in
the f6 pawn if he goes to e3 he's
sitting this pawn the white square for
the bishop is here where it supports
this pawn advance doesn't get in the way
of the rook and maybe wants some pawn
straight off the bishop can come here or
here and then go this way and the bishop
here helps defend anything happening
over here so the only the correct
retreat is Bishop to d2 the computer
says but Knight to f6 and then what then
see he played he played before but he
should have played the bishop up first
that black moved the knight pin the
night that makes this stronger because
the Knights further away from the action
he'd play h6 now the bishop takes the
knight and the Queen takes takes here if
he takes pawn back he loses that pawn
and the rook attacks the night so now
we're a real pawn up his best move is to
give up a pawn Knight to a6
pawn takes he can take that pawn back
with the Queen and then he blocks this
pawn attacking the bishop it's not an
aggressive move he moved here to block
the egg whites extra pawn and there's no
pawn to chase it away this is a great
square for the knight and the knight
defends this pawn so this writ can't
take the pawn then the Queen takes the
pawn and black and defend this position
even though he's a pawn down white would
just move up here having moved his pawns
here in here this Knight needs to be
reinforced so the Queen can move the
Queen with that Queen on the knight now
the King protects it so the Queen can
move somewhere and the King protects the
h3 pawn and depending on what happens a
kid slide over to the kingside on the
first row and help defend the king site
or even he could start a pawn attack in
the future on the kingside now look at
how the computer evaluates it 0.81 he
see this is a big advantage this is what
white should have done now all white did
in this position not this position right
here
he played b4 one move too early and it
went down point five one had he played
the bishop move and then the knight pin
and then played b4 he ends up with a
point eight one advantage so it's these
minor little things that have a big
impact
okay so 0.51 we're back to a half pont
advantage that's like your first move
advantage blacks had no real danger of
losing but it has to continue to defend
and try to reduce white's small
advantage black plays b6 this move is
commonly played in Brno knees to shore
up this pawn pawn takes you can take
back with this pawn or maybe this pawn
and then you can move a knight and put a
knight here and block the pawn and if
you keep these bonds here
it keeps the rook out but it's the wrong
idea
it's the C this is defensive black is
its defect just defending but I can be a
little more active than just pure
defensive the computer says that maybe
he should have taken here and white
takes back now see how this pawn guards
this square so the knight can't come up
here and block this pawn
and white wants to play this pawn up he
can't do it right away he'll put the
bishop here and then he'll bring the
Queen here and maybe the work here and
then he can push here and attack this
pod so black plays a good move he
attacks the pawn here to work so there's
not to pawn side by side and this pawn
can never go here white takes you take
with the rook now the rook has an open
file and the knight can hop in here with
a good square he does lose a pawn the
knight hops up chases the rook back and
then this writ comes down here and pins
the bishop and it's going to cost white
some moves to unwind the position but
white is a solid pawn up and the
computer says this would be 0.72
advantage anyway
b6 now white misses the second
opportunity to play Bishop to g5 and
attack the Queen the same reason holds
the Queen either retreats to e8 moves
the knight to a pin or f6 and then he's
weakened his pawn structure and then you
could go not to e3 the bishop belongs on
d2 so the computer says Bishop to e3
look at the evaluation it went from 0.72
to 0.40 almost equality now 0.72 was
almost a pawn up now we're down to just
a little more than 1/3 of a pawn so the
computer doesn't like that move says he
should have done this and I give it an
exclamation mark which means good move
f6 then the bishop goes to d2
takes takes and now here's not such a
good move because you take and he can't
take with the rook because the bishops
on it he'd take with the pawn and the
RIC can come down here and attack this
Knight
White has a big advantage and the best
move is he moves that rook over there to
defend the pawns and he wants to trade
rooks when white advances his pawns and
this would be a point back to a point
seven nine that would maintain our awe
or almost upon advantage bless the fifth
so it's a 4/5 of upon advantage so
anyway
Bishop to e3 was not the right square he
should have attacked the Queen and if he
didn't want to attack the Queen he
should have gone to d2
rickover knight came back that night
maybe coming up here then he can take
here and if the knight takes he can take
back something like that now black makes
a big mistake he voluntarily plays f6
there was no need to play f6 and it
blocks the Queen the Queen has a
diagonal up toward H fiber can attack
the h3 pawn maybe play h5 attacking the
g4 pawn biplane f6 he shut his queen out
he reduced his future moves so that's
why it's a bad move and look over there
the computer says now + / - that's a big
advantage we're up to 0.94 of a pawn
well white places rook up you'll notice
that black all his pieces
forget the pawns all those pieces are on
two rows this is called a big space
advantage for white this is why they
don't play the old-fashioned Benoni you
don't want to be cramped like this you
want to have your pieces moving into
enemy territory you don't want to be
playing on your last two rows so blacks
it into real trouble he drops the knight
here gonna come up here and looks like
and black doesn't have a lot of good
moves so he puts the night over there
Knight comes up here he tries g5 he
doesn't want white to get f4 or h4 ideas
so he's trying to block the position and
play for a draw by blocking all the
pawns white opens up the spec file see
when the knight move had the knight
stayed here white wouldn't do pawn takes
because the knight could take back
blocking the pawn and it would cost him
a good Bishop to get rid of the knight
so he wouldn't do pawn takes pawn when
he moved to the knight to f8 it now it
allows pawn takes pawn and either pawn
takes back as the look is not so good he
takes with the D pawn that's the right
way to take it you don't want to open up
this file for the work by taking pawn
takes white plays up here now he's gonna
play the knight up here and if that
Knight takes
he'll take with this pawn then it'll
open up this file to this backward pawn
and he'll pile up works and Queens and
win that pawn black comes up this was
his idea with that Knight maneuver he
wants to go here and attack this pawn
and this Bishop not a bad idea but it
wasn't the right idea in this particular
game okay so he didn't do the knight
move
he's attacking the pawns if pawn takes
pawn he can't defend that pawn the Queen
the Queen can't come up here but the
Queen could come over here and get the
pawn back and then that rook could come
here and he'd have to works on the open
file he brings his queen up there's a
rule on chest that you need to block
this is a passed pawn
they need to be blocked but do you block
past pawns with your most valuable piece
no chess theory says one of the Knights
belongs here now had he a black square
bishop you block pawns with nicer
bishops they like Knights best because
the knight blocks the pawn and the
knight can hop around the pond and have
a lot of good moves a bishop is second
choice if there was a black bishop here
it'd be blocked by his pawns II wouldn't
have any future moves so that night is
the best block hater the Queen is the
worst block a derp and the computer says
that's a mistake and now we're up to
1.33 up we're up a pawn in a third bonds
are still even so this is a position a
big positional advantage and I got a
little note that black had a better
defense had he brought the rook over
here just to hold the pawn not blocked
with the Queen and that's 0.98 still
about upon advantage but less than one
one and a third pawns okay
anyway white brings his queen up
threatening to win this pawn so black
rushes his rook over now black is
thinking he's threatening pawn takes
pawn the rook will be on the Queen
and apparently white thought so too
because white moved the Queen away from
the rook where it protects the pawn but
that was not the right move see how the
evaluation dropped 0.89 from 1.33 that's
a 44 that's almost half a pawn drop
still a big advantage what the computer
said he should have done if pawn takes
pawn he can do Queen takes rook and get
two rooks for the Queen and the rook
will be here attacking the bishop pinned
to the king you want your work to
penetrate to the back row the right move
was to move this work here and if pawn
takes pawn you win the rooks and then
this work can take this pawn and you
threaten to win this pond and it would
be a win so let's go through what the
computer says we're here
Black's best is to bring his knight up
attacking the bishop that's now
unprotected and the pawn we don't take
the knight we want to keep our black
squirt our two bishops we have a good
move
we just retreat the bishop see how it
defends the pawn on h3 and the knight
can't go anywhere because the bishop
guards all of the squares and when
things open up that Bishop can come out
later on in the game and the computer
says this is a 1.43 advantage now
instead of Knight f4 had he done pawn
takes pawn
see how it's the mistake we get the two
rooks and the computer says that this is
four point six six pawn advantage that's
a massive winning advantage so when
white moved to the Queen here he should
have brought the rook he
when you you have your queen and working
in an attacking position don't be afraid
to get to works for the Queen you bring
in the other attacking work you really
pile up and black could not have
defended his position anyway still in a
bad way white still 0.9 of a pawn
advantage he brings to the knight up
again the bishop drops back he tries to
weaken White's pawns but white can
reinforce the pawn with f3 Bishop comes
in blacks not going to be able to break
through in a timely fashion on the Kings
side white doubles up rooks he's
breaking through on the Queen side for
sure the pawn takes each pawn takes
keeping you got to keep you pawn chains
intact so and you the rule is to take
toward the center so H pawn is the
normal now it does there is an open H
file but look the rooks are over here
and the Queen's over here they can't go
over to the H file to come down and try
to checkmate the black the white King
black panics and makes a bad move he's
in the lost position though he play he
he sacrifices the bishop hoping we've
we've all done this you're you're under
a lot of pressure you're losing the game
so you do a sacrifice hoping for a
miracle attack and if your opponent
doesn't answer it properly you might
pull out a draw or even win if you're
lucky so that's what black tries but
he's playing a group one of the top
players in the world who knows exactly
how to defend so this is a bad an
unsound sacrifice of a bishop and look
it's you don't see it but it's 3.23
pot is the advantage for white after
that the the somewhat better but still
losing would have been
to a 8 and that's one-and-a-half pawn
advantage so white would win even with
the better move but blacks dead loss now
pawn takes Queen comes over to pick up
the pawn bishop defends the pawn the
only way to get that pawn is to give up
that very strong knight on f4 but that
brings the rook over where it helps
defend the King side Queen takes rook
goes there that e4 pawn is protected by
the knight Queen has to move now the
white queen hurries back to come over to
the King side help defend King up so the
rook can come over night whoops
knight Knight comes back to help defend
now if the rook came over and the Queen
got down here the King just moves up
here and these two protect so that that
doesn't win for black anyway he tries it
but white stops it with this nice move
Knight to g3 covering the h1 square and
the knight is aiming for the f5 square
and it defends the 4 pawn and there's
absolutely nothing black can do makes a
few more moves now the Queen comes over
and that pawn on f6 is pinned to the
king and white threatens Bishop takes
pawn black was probably in time trouble
but he was lost anyway losing that pawn
with Queen takes pawn check to follow
was more than enough so black resigned
the opening they play pretty well but
black kind of caved in at the later on
in the game
all right well it'll covered for tonight
thanks for coming